Grazie.
Beh, buonasera a tutti. Dunque, per prima cosa io vi devo avvertire che voi stasera siete caduti in una trappola, nel senso che normalmente le lezioni di questo festival e anche degli altri durano un'oretta, un'ora.
Allora, la quarta crociata è una questione talmente complessa che io in meno di un'ora e mezza non riesco a raccontarvela.
Se qualcuno deve andare via prima è autorizzato comunque, sia chiaro.
Allora, no, dunque, stasera parliamo di crociate. Raccontiamo, anzi, una crociata, la quarta.
Sapete che le crociate per comodità sono numerate, di solito se ne contano otto o nove.
E quella di cui parliamo oggi è la quarta che si colloca nei primissimi anni del Duecento e che fra tutte è quella che ha l'esito più sorprendente, più inaspettato,
nel senso che anziché andare a Gerusalemme, i crociati alla fine, per una serie di circostanze, andranno a Costantinopoli e conquisteranno Costantinopoli,
la capitale dell'impero bizantino. Questa storia io ve la racconterò usando spesso le parole di tre testimoni oculari,
due che erano nell'esercito crociato e uno che invece era a Costantinopoli e che se li ha visti arrivare.
Ma ve li presenterò un po' per volta man mano che mi arrivano di fronte.
Prima parliamo però un po' in generale, diciamo, di quello che è il tema di fondo, cioè che cosa sono le crociate.
Le crociate si possono raccontare in tanti modi.
Si possono raccontare come imprese dettate dall'imperialismo, dalla volontà di conquista e di guadagno.
Le crociate si possono anche raccontare, volendo, come la prima manifestazione di quella spinta coloniale
che nei secoli successivi porterà gli europei a conquistare l'America e l'Africa e gran parte dell'Asia.
Può sembrare anacronistico perché noi colleghiamo il colonialismo comunque all'età moderna,
ma se ci pensate le crociate sono la prima volta dopo la caduta dell'impero romano
in cui degli eserciti e delle flotte partono dall'Europa per andare a conquistare territori in altri continenti.
Ora tutto questo è una descrizione assolutamente corretta.
Le crociate sono grandi imprese di conquista per conquistare territori, fondare regni e fare bottino.
Ma quelli che ci andavano non le avrebbero mai raccontate così.
Certo, loro lo sapevano benissimo, non erano mica scemi neanche loro, e neanche ingenui per niente.
Loro lo sapevano benissimo che spesso chi partiva era motivato anche dalla voglia di arricchirsi.
Ma magari semplicemente di cogliere un'occasione per cambiare vita.
Perché capite che partire per una crociata voleva dire essere sicuri di stare via per anni
e magari se capitava l'occasione non tornare mai più.
Lo sapevano benissimo che una delle motivazioni importanti che spingevano a partire
era anche, se vogliamo metterla in modo elegante, il desiderio di avventura e di vedere il mondo.
Ma poi anche molto concretamente il desiderio di arricchirsi.
Lo sapevano tutti.
E però per loro era ovvio che il vero motivo, il motivo principale per cui quegli eserciti partivano
è che i cristiani dovevano possedere Gerusalemme, la città santa della loro religione.
Ed era intollerabile che Gerusalemme fosse lasciata in mano agli infedeli.
Ecco, quando e perché a un certo punto in Europa, fra i cristiani d'Europa,
sia nata questa convinzione che era indispensabile possedere Gerusalemme,
qui non staremo a raccontarlo.
Però dobbiamo accettare, dovete accettare, che gli uomini di cui racconteremo questa sera
sono partiti per la crociata e vivevano in un mondo in cui già i loro genitori e i loro nonni
lo davano per scontato.
Gerusalemme deve essere nostra.
E quelli che ci comandano hanno il preciso dovere di spendere le loro risorse
per realizzare questo obiettivo.
Ecco, capite, noi di fronte a questa loro convinzione
possiamo reagire come reagivano gli illuministi del Settecento,
Voltaire e Diderot,
i quali pensavano che le crociate fossero la prova
di quanto possono essere stupidi gli esseri umani.
E rimanevano sbalorditi all'idea che ci fosse stata un'epoca
in cui la gente era così scema,
cito,
un'epoca di tenebre così profonde
e di stordimento così grande
fra i popoli
e fra i sovrani
sui loro veri interessi
da poter trascinare una parte del mondo
in un disgraziato piccolo paese
che sarebbe la Palestina naturalmente
allo scopo di sgozzare gli abitanti
e impadronirsi di un pezzo di roccia
che non valeva una goccia di sangue.
Così Diderot, se non sbaglio.
Oppure possiamo anche, se volete,
riflettere
sul fatto che ancora oggi
la questione se Gerusalemme
sia oppure no
la capitale dello Stato di Israele
è tuttora una questione
che muove le cancellerie internazionali
e che fa versare del sangue.
Se preferite potremmo anche chiederci
se spendere miliardi
e morire per il Vietnam
o per la Crimea
sia una cosa tanto più razionale
e diversa rispetto alla loro convinzione
che valeva la pena di morire per Gerusalemme.
Ma il punto non è questo.
Quel che conta è che noi dobbiamo accettare.
Notate che io non sto dicendo necessariamente
che sia assurdo morire per la Crimea.
Sto dicendo che non era forse assurdo
morire per Gerusalemme
nel loro sistema di valori
nella loro visione del mondo.
In ogni caso
loro la pensavano così
conquistare Gerusalemme
è una missione per il mondo cristiano
e a nessuno poteva venire in mente
di discuterlo.
O meglio
forse a uno è venuto in mente
si chiamava Francesco D'Assisi
però questa è un'altra storia
e ve la racconterò un'altra volta.
Lui è l'unico
che a un certo punto
probabilmente ha avuto l'idea
ma forse stiamo sbagliando tutto.
Questa roba non ha senso.
Ma invece tutti quelli
di cui vi racconterò stasera
erano convinti
che avesse assolutamente senso.
Conquistare Gerusalemme
è un dovere del mondo cristiano.
E in effetti
cent'anni prima
l'avevano conquistata
con quella che noi chiamiamo
la prima crociata.
Parentesi
chiariamola una volta per tutte.
loro non le chiamavano crociate
la parola crociata
è una parola moderna.
Loro dicevano
il santo viaggio
oppure il passaggio generale.
E i crociati
beh i crociati qualche volta
si chiamavano così
la parola ce l'avevano.
Perché uno è un crociato?
Perché quando hai fatto voto
di partire
ti fai cucire una croce
sull'abito
che tutti la vedano
che tu hai preso
questo impegno
e quindi sei un
come dicevano
nelle loro fonti latine
un cruce signatum
segnato con la croce
un crociato
però in realtà
la parola la usavano poco.
Normalmente
i nostri testimoni
della quarta crociata
di cui vi parlerò
e di cui sentiremo le parole
loro quando parlavano
di se stessi
che erano partiti da casa
dicevano
i pellegrini
perché era un pellegrinaggio
ogni spedizione.
Dicevo
cent'anni prima
Gerusalemme
era stata conquistata
o liberata
come dirà
Torquato Tasso
secoli dopo
ma in un mondo
in cui l'idea
della crociata
del fatto che cristiani
e musulmani
inevitabilmente
devono combattersi
beh ancora
il tempo del Tasso
era ancora ben chiara
Gerusalemme liberata
era stata conquistata
Gerusalemme
e i cristiani
l'avevano tenuta
per quasi un secolo
e poi i musulmani
avevano trovato
un capo
più in gamba
degli altri
si chiamava
Yusuf
Ibn Ayyub
Giuseppe
figlio di Giobbe
soprannome
Salaheddin
la rettitudine
della fede
per noi
il Saladino
e già per Dante
che era nato
a Tikrit
come Saddam Hussein
nel 1187
quasi 90 anni
dopo la prima
crociata
annienta
l'esercito
del regno
di Gerusalemme
nella battaglia
di Hattin
sul lago
di Tiberiade
quello dove
Gesù camminava
sulle acque
e il Saladino
riconquista
Gerusalemme
ovviamente
il fatto che
gli infedeli
dopo 90 anni
hanno riconquistato
Gerusalemme
suscita
un'enorme
emozione
nell'Europa cristiana
a partire da quel momento
il mondo cristiano
si mobilita
parte subito
una crociata
la terza
che alla fine
non ce la fa
a riprendere
Gerusalemme
e a quel punto
appunto
sull'agenda
di tutti i leader
del mondo cristiano
organizzare
una nuova crociata
e andarci
a riprendere
Gerusalemme
è in alto
nell'agenda
è uno dei principali
obiettivi
nel gennaio
viene eletto
un nuovo Papa
Innocenzo III
giusto per capirci
e per dare l'idea
di come il mondo
medievale
era diverso
dal nostro
quando noi
immaginiamo
l'elezione
di un nuovo Papa
vabbè
credo che tutti quanti
ci facciamo
una certa immagine
Innocenzo III
quando viene eletto Papa
ha 36 anni
è la cosa
perfettamente normale
e questo Papa
di 36 anni
immediatamente
comincia
a cercare
di convincere
i sovrani cristiani
che è il loro
preciso dovere
mobilitare
le loro risorse
e partire
per riprendersi
Gerusalemme
sono passati
pochi mesi
da quando è stato eletto
il 15 agosto
del 1198
festa
dell'assunzione
Innocenzo III
manda una circolare
a tutti
i sovrani
e i principi cristiani
manda una circolare
la cancelleria papale
a Roma
è un organismo
di governo
poderoso
con una moltitudine
di chierici
in grado
di mandare
in pochi giorni
copie
della stessa lettera
a tutti i principi
a tutti i vescovi
dell'Europa cristiana
e le lettere
di Innocenzo III
invitano tutti
a mollare
le altre cose
di cui si stanno occupando
e partire
per la Terra Santa
tutti
è chiaro
che più sono importanti
quelli che vanno
meglio è
Innocenzo III
ha in mente
soprattutto
i re
dell'Europa cristiana
due sono i re
più potenti
in quel momento
Filippo II
re di Francia
e Riccardo
soprannominato
cuor di leone
re di Inghilterra
Filippo
e Riccardo
erano già stati
qualche anno prima
alla terza crociata
e
avevano litigato
così furiosamente
che al ritorno
dalla crociata
si erano dichiarati
guerra
e si stavano
ancora combattendo
adesso il papa
sperava
e lo dice
nel suo appello
lo dice
che facciano la pace
e che ripartano
per la Terra Santa
di questi due re
i più potenti
d'Europa
Filippo
re di Francia
non era un guerriero
Riccardo invece
sì
Riccardo cuor di leone
era un grande
guerriero
era l'unico
comandante cristiano
che durante
la terza crociata
fosse riuscito
a vincere
una battaglia
contro il Saladino
la battaglia
di Arsuf
che non era bastata
per riconquistare
Gerusalemme
però era bastata
per riconquistare
un porto
il porto di Giaffa
per cui i cristiani
conservavano
capite
una testa di ponte
in Terra Santa
io penso
che Papa
Innocenzo III
sperasse
soprattutto
in Riccardo
che era
esaltato
dai trovatori
dai poeti
che lui pagava
generosamente
e quindi
ovviamente
era esaltato
dai trovatori
come
il cavaliere
più coraggioso
e più generoso
del mondo
e pazienza
se aveva
una certa tendenza
a massacrare
i prigionieri
solo che
il 26 marzo
del 1199
il re Riccardo
che stava
assediando
un castello
in Francia
fu ferito
alla spalla
da un colpo
di balestra
la ferita
andò in cancrena
e 11 giorni dopo
Riccardo
era morto
quanto al re
Filippo
di Francia
non sembra
che abbia visto
nella morte di Riccardo
un segnale
si è guardato
bene
dall'impegnarsi
a partire
e ovviamente
voi capite
neanche il fratellino
di Riccardo
il re Giovanni
il quale aveva
altre grane
in casa sua
a questo punto
la spinta
per la partenza
della crociata
rischia di rallentare
viene fuori
un grande predicatore
che si chiama
Folco di Neuilly
che in Francia
lancia
una grande campagna
di predicazione
per la crociata
tenete presente
che all'epoca
i grandi predicatori
sono delle star
sono delle persone
che sono capaci
di stare su un palco
e parlare per ore
a un pubblico
che sta in piedi
o in ginocchio
non seduto
ecco
e tenere in pugno
per ore e ore
un pubblico enorme
e farlo piangere
e farlo ridere
i predicatori
sono una potenza
all'epoca
e Folco di Neuilly
è incaricato
dal Papa
di investire
nella predicazione
della crociata
Folco di Neuilly
è un grande predicatore
che parla
della povertà
cioè del tema
che è di moda
in quel momento
perché in quel momento
in un mondo cristiano
che sta crescendo
sta diventando
sempre più ricco
più complesso
capite
banalmente
c'è sempre più gente
che sa leggere
e la gente
cosa legge?
Legge il Vangelo
per prima cosa
vogliono leggere quello
e la brava gente
che legge il Vangelo
da sola
a casa
per la prima volta
in vita sua
scopre che Gesù
e gli Apostoli
andavano scalzi
mica come il Vescovo
che va a cavallo
quando mai Gesù
è andato a cavallo
tranne l'asino
Gesù andava a piedi
scalzo
erano poveri
lavoravano
questa scoperta
che il cristianesimo
è una religione
per i poveri
è una cosa
che sciocca
la società
di quest'epoca
e quelli
come Folco di Noi
diventano famosi
proprio con la capacità
di convincere la gente
che il cristianesimo
non è soltanto
la religione
del Papa
dei Vescovi
dei Potenti
ma è una religione
che pensa anche a voi
anche alla gente
anche ai poveri
a quelli che soffrono
Folco di Noi
è incaricato
di predicare
la crociata
e nell'inverno
fra il 1199
e il 1200
alcuni
tra i più grandi
principi
della Francia
del Nord
decidono
di prendere
la croce
il conte
di Champagne
di Blois
il conte
di Fiandra
di Saint Paul
e per ogni
conte
che prende
la croce
ci sono decine
dei suoi grandi
vassalli
che prendono
la croce
con lui
e ognuno
si porta dietro
decine
di suoi cavalieri
quindi in realtà
in questo momento
si prefigura
la possibilità
di far partire
un grande esercito
dalla Francia
il primo
dei nostri testimoni
è uno
dei gran signori
che hanno preso
la croce
quell'inverno
convinti
dalla predicazione
di Folco
di Noi
si chiama
Geoffroy
de Villardouin
era un vassallo
del conte
di Champagne
era il maresciallo
che vuol dire
il comandante
dell'esercito
del conte
di Champagne
un gran signore
uno di quelli
che possiedono
tanti castelli
e decine
di cavalieri
ai loro ordini
Geoffroy de Villardouin
lo racconta
a quell'epoca
dice c'era un santuomo
che predicava
la crociata
e il papa
aveva fatto
grandi promesse
perché ovviamente
il papa
nel momento
in cui lancia
l'idea
di una crociata
deve offrire
qualcosa
cosa offre
offre ricompense
spirituali
offre la soluzione
dai peccati
e per questa gente
che di peccati
ne commette
tanti
ma che ci crede
che poi dopo la morte
arrivano un diavolo
e un angelo
a decidere
da che parte andrai
ecco
per questa gente
la soluzione
dai peccati
è una cosa
concreta
grossa
per cui vale la pena
di rischiare
la pelle
Geoffroy de Villardouin
maresciallo
di Champagne
il papa
aveva promesso
che tutti
quelli
che avessero
preso la croce
e compiuto
il servizio
di Dio
per un anno
nella spedizione
sarebbero
assolti
di tutti
i peccati
che avessero
confessato
e poiché
il perdono
era così
grande
si commossero
molto
i cuori
della gente
e perciò
molti
presero
la croce
poiché
il perdono
era così
grande
e ognuno
di loro
se la raccontava
certamente così
quando ho saputo
che il papa
aveva promesso
la soluzione
da tutti
i peccati
beh
come potevo
stare a casa
poi naturalmente
uno va a vedere
scopre anche
che alcuni
di quei principi
nella grande guerra
fra il re di Francia
e il re Riccardo
di Inghilterra
si erano schierati
con il re Riccardo
e adesso
che il re Riccardo
era morto
all'improvviso
si trovavano
un pochino
scoperti
e allora
partire
per la crociata
è anche un modo
per uscire
da una situazione
politica
che all'improvviso
è diventata difficile
è un modo
per dire al re di Francia
guarda
non preoccuparti
perché tanto io
me ne vado
le mie terre
le lascio a governare
mia moglie
sotto la protezione
della chiesa
perché chi parte
per la crociata
la chiesa
si impegna
a proteggere
quello che lascia
a casa
è un modo
per uscire
da una situazione
complicata
va anche detto
ecco
questo è uno
di quei dettagli
che allungano
la lezione
che ero incerto
fino all'ultimo
se tagliare o no
poi non sono riuscito
a tagliare niente
questi partono
per la crociata
benissimo
ma il conte di Champagne
che ha 22 anni
parte per la quarta crociata
suo padre
aveva partecipato
alla seconda
il suo fratello maggiore
aveva partecipato
alla terza
il conte di Blois
era già stato
alla terza
Geoffroy de Villardouin
che vi citerò
ancora spesso
uno di questi
gran signori
che partono
aveva partecipato
alla terza
era stato catturato
dai saraceni
era rimasto
in prigionia
per diversi anni
prima di essere
riscattato
e tornare a casa
e adesso
non vede l'ora
di partire
di nuovo
questa è una cosa
come dire
che ci deve far riflettere
per cercare di capire
cosa aveva in testa
questa gente
bene
quindi
molti principi francesi
con i loro vassalli
hanno preso la croce
ce n'è abbastanza
per mettere in campo
un esercito
formidabile
quindi uno dice
possono partire
fra gli applausi
di quelli che restano
le lacrime
delle mogli
piano
possono partire
calma
perché erano finiti
da un pezzo
i tempi
in cui un gran signore
partiva
e i suoi vassalli
automaticamente
erano impegnati
ad andare con lui
perché in cambio
delle terre
che avevano ricevuto
in feudo dal capo
erano obbligati
a servirlo
ogni volta che lui
lo chiedeva
non sono più
quei tempi
l'Europa
dell'anno 1200
è un'economia
in crescita
formidabile
ecco
dal tempo
della prima crociata
l'Europa
è cambiata
come è cambiata
la Cina
dalla Cina di Mao
alla Cina di oggi
nell'Europa
del 1200
senza soldi
non si fa niente
di soldi
ne girano tanti
nessuno muove
un dito
se non è pagato
e dunque
un cavaliere
va in guerra
quando il suo signore
glielo chiede
ma vuole essere pagato
e a maggior ragione
devono essere pagati
gli altri
perché un esercito
non è fatto soltanto
di cavalieri
in armatura
è fatto di arcieri
di balestrieri
di combattenti
a piedi
i quali sono
dei mercenari
professionisti
bisogna pagarli
non solo
a tutta questa gente
migliaia di cavalieri
decine di migliaia
di combattenti
a piedi
migliaia di cavalli
a tutta questa gente
bisogna andare da mangiare
e quindi sono forniture
di pane
di vino
di carne
di fieno
di biada
perché i cavalli
costano
quanto gli uomini
se non di più
da mantenere
in sostanza
ci vogliono
dei fondi
nessuna spedizione
può partire
se non vengono stanziati
i fondi
i crociati stessi
contribuiscono
un gran signore
il conte di champagne
che prende la croce
può anche impegnarsi
a pagare
i suoi cavalieri
e i suoi arcieri
che lo seguono
però nell'insieme
bisogna raccogliere
un sacco di soldi
anche il papa
deve contribuire
folco di noi
che predica
la crociata
viene incaricato
anche di raccogliere
i finanziamenti
e qui naturalmente
c'è il paradosso
di un predicatore
il quale è diventato famoso
parlando della povertà
e che adesso
a un certo punto
comincia a raccogliere
i soldi
che dovranno servire
per pagare
la spedizione
non ci vuol niente
perché nell'Europa cristiana
comincino a correre
i pettegolezzi
su dove sono finiti
i soldi
che sta raccogliendo
folco di noi
popolarissimo
amatissimo
ma dopo un po'
folco viene a sapere
che in giro
si sparla di lui
tutti quei soldi
si sono mica visti
finora
chi ha reso conti
dove sono i conti
ecco
il papa stesso
deve annunciare
che la chiesa
si impegnerà
per tirar fuori
i soldi
il clero
sarà
tassato
innocenzo terzo
nel dicembre
del 99
annuncia
una tassa
sulle entrate
del clero
in tutta Europa
dalla Sicilia
alla Svezia
il clero
pagherà
un quarantesimo
delle sue
entrate
per finanziare
la crociata
ora di nuovo
per capire
che mondo
è quello
un quarantesimo
è ovviamente
il 2,5%
a noi
abituati
alle nostre imposte
l'idea
di dover pagare
il 2,5%
ecco
ci fa ridere
come vedo
che ridete
in quel mondo
è uno scandalo
gigantesco
il papa
sa benissimo
che il clero
farà di tutto
per non dover pagare
questa tassa
pazzesca
per dover
tirar fuori
tutti questi soldi
tanto che deve garantire
che
non farà
precedente
se pagate
non verremo
l'anno prossimo
a chiederveli
di nuovo
ecco
dopodiché
perché ci vogliono
tanti soldi
in parte
l'abbiamo detto
perché tutta questa gente
va pagata
e nutrita
ma c'è anche
un altro motivo
ed è di nuovo
della serie
non sono più
i tempi
di cent'anni fa
al tempo
della prima
crociata
i crociati
partiti
dalla Francia
dalla Germania
erano andati
a Gerusalemme
e c'erano andati
a piedi
attraversando
l'Europa
i Balcani
l'impero bizantino
la Turchia
e poi finalmente
arrivando a Gerusalemme
adesso
non è più pensabile
il mondo è un altro
il mondo è cambiato
nessuno pensa più
che un viaggio del genere
si faccia
a piedi
perché?
perché ci sono
le città italiane
ci sono quelle
che noi chiamiamo
le repubbliche marinare
loro non le chiamavano mica così
ma insomma
ci sono Venezia
Pisa
Genova
anche Amalfi
hanno delle flotte
controllano
il Mediterraneo
cent'anni prima
erano appena agli inizi
adesso ci sono
il Mediterraneo
è in mano
alle flotte italiane
e ovviamente
se vogliamo andare
di là del mare
ci andiamo via mare
mica a piedi
quindi
quindi bisogna
contattare
questi italiani
per capire
quanto costerebbe
trasportarci
tutti quanti
dall'altra parte
del mare
perché quelli
mica lo fanno gratis
hai voglia
prendono vari contatti
alla fine
decidono
di discutere
seriamente
con i veneziani
mandano una missione
di grandi baroni
a Venezia
il nostro testimone
Villardouin
Geoffroy de Villardouin
è uno
dei baroni
che vengono
mandati
a Venezia
e ci racconta
il suo viaggio
a Venezia
ci siamo arrivati lì
abbiamo parlato
col Doge
il Doge
è uno dei grossi
personaggi
della nostra storia
lo menzionerò
ancora spesso
si chiamava
Enrico Dandolo
era vecchio
cieco
astutissimo
dicono tutti
governava
Venezia
con straordinaria
abilità
Villardouin
e gli altri
vanno dal Doge
gli spiegano
così e così
partono i più
grandi principi
dalla Francia
un grande esercito
abbiamo bisogno
di essere trasportati
al delà del mare
quanto costerebbe
se siedono
intorno a un tavolo
e cominciano a fare
due conti
e alla fine
arrivano a stabilire
il prezzo
del biglietto
loro calcolano
che l'esercito
comprenderà
4.500 cavalieri
e 20.000 uomini
a piedi
e quindi
anche
4.500 cavalli
i veneziani
preparano
il capitolato
d'appalto
per trasportare
di là del mare
e accompagnare
e nutrire
rifornire
per nove mesi
un esercito
di quelle dimensioni
il prezzo
sarà di
quattro marchi
d'argento
per un cavallo
e due marchi
per un uomo
per un totale
di 85.000
marchi
che cos'è
il marco
tenete presente
che a quell'epoca
in Europa
non circolava
moneta d'oro
la moneta d'oro
aveva smesso
di coniarla
già Carlo Magno
e per secoli
l'Europa
era stata troppo povera
per potersi permettere
di avere moneta d'oro
adesso
all'inizio
del duecento
l'Europa
è in piena
crescita economica
e fra poco
le città italiane
decideranno
che tutto sommato
la moneta d'oro
ce la possiamo permettere
e Firenze
conierà
il fiorino
e Venezia
e Genova
conieranno
il ducato d'oro
ma questo
Federico II
al sud
conierà
l'augustale
d'oro
ma manca ancora
qualche anno
in quel momento
si usa solo
moneta d'argento
il marco
che poi ovviamente
è diventato
il nome della moneta
tedesca
in epoca moderna
all'epoca
il marco
non è una moneta
è un'unità di peso
che varia
da una zona
all'altra
ma grosso modo
possono essere
due etti e mezzo
d'argento
in sostanza
un cavaliere
col suo cavallo
e due scudieri
avrebbe speso
due chili e mezzo
d'argento
per pagarsi
il biglietto
del viaggio
il totale
di 85.000
marchi
corrisponde
a più di
20 tonnellate
d'argento
vi devo dire subito
che i prezzi attuali
dell'argento
non è neanche tanto
rispetto ai prezzi
dei biglietti aerei
attuali
tutto sommato
ma rispetto
all'equilibrio
dei prezzi
dell'epoca
ovviamente
è una somma
colossale
dopodiché
il doge
dopo che hanno steso
questo capitolato
rilancia
dice questo è
l'accordo commerciale
ma noi veniamo
con voi
partecipiamo
anche noi
alla crociata
e siccome
di sicuro
faremo
delle conquiste
noi
ci impegniamo
ad accompagnarvi
con 50 galere
da guerra
e cito
da Villarduain
dice Villarduain
il doge
ci ha detto
e finché
la nostra
compagnia
durerà
di tutte
le conquiste
che faremo
e di bottino
faremo
a metà
ora
consigliatevi
se potrete
farlo
e se vi sta bene
voi capite
il doge
di Venezia
sta proponendo
una compagnia
commerciale
la cultura
delle città italiane
è già
a quel livello
noi investiamo
creiamo
una compagnia
faremo
dei profitti
e i profitti
ce li spartiamo
a metà
a questo punto
Villarduain
assiste
ai meccanismi
decisionali
di un comune
italiano
dove non è
che uno decide
a casa nostra
il conte di champagne
si consulta
con i suoi principali
vassalli
e poi decide
qui no
il doge di Venezia
deve riunire
il suo consiglio
ristretto
poi un consiglio
allargato
poi un altro
ancora più allargato
dice Villarduain
era molto bravo
li ha convinti
tutti
ad accettare
questo accordo
e alla fine
il doge
ha convocato
l'assemblea
del popolo
diecimila uomini
dice Villarduain
nella cappella
di San Marco
la più bella
che ci sia
fa dire
messa
e poi
invita
gli ambasciatori
dei crociati
a spiegare
loro stessi
al popolo
veneziano
qual è
la loro missione
e segue
una scena
che è veramente
emblematica
del tipo di
come dire
di comportamenti
e di reazioni
degli uomini
di quell'epoca
che possono essere
in circostanze
come questa
estremamente
emotivi
Villarduain
dice
e noi
noi ci siamo
trovati lì
che il doge
ci ha detto
spiegate voi
al popolo
e noi abbiamo
detto
signori
i baroni
di Francia
più nobili
e potenti
ci hanno
mandati da voi
e implorano
la vostra
grazia
che abbiate
pietà
di Gerusalemme
che è
in servaggio
dei turchi
che per
Dio
li vogliate
accompagnare
a vendicare
l'onta
di Gesù Cristo
e hanno
scelto
voi
veneziani
perché sanno
che nessun
popolo
che vada
per mare
è potente
quanto voi
e ci hanno
comandato
di cadervi
ai piedi
e di non
alzarci
finché
non avrete
accordato
di avere
pietà
della terra
santa
d'oltremare
e a questo
punto
si inginocchiano
davanti a tutti
piangendo
e tutti
si mettono
a piangere
e tutti
si mettono
a gridare
sì sì
lo concediamo
e c'era
un rumore
un chiasso
tale
che sembrava
che il mondo
crollasse
ecco
l'appello emotivo
la capacità
di mettersi
a piangere
il richiamo
all'onore
e all'onta
alla vergogna
e alla vendetta
sono tutte cose
che nell'animo
degli uomini
di quell'epoca
hanno una forza
e il doge
si rivolge
al popolo
e dice
vedete
signori
l'onore
che Dio
vi ha fatto
che la miglior
gente
del mondo
ha chiesto
la vostra
compagnia
per fare
insieme
una cosa
così nobile
come la riscossa
di nostro
signore
quindi
meraviglioso
tutti piangono
tutti applaudono
sono tutti
d'accordo
l'accordo
è fatto
a questo punto
bisogna pagare
la prima rata
85.000 marchi
ma la prima rata
è anticipata
e gli ambasciatori
prendono in prestito
5.000 marchi
in Venezia
stessa
e li pagano
al doge
li consegnano
per cominciare
la fabbricazione
della flotta
un dettaglio
abbiamo detto
finora
per andare
al di là
del mare
ma esattamente
dove
mica andavano
alla cieca
si stabiliva
esattamente
una strategia
e mentre
in passato
l'idea era
sbarchiamo
in terra santa
e spacchiamo
tutto
adesso
l'esperienza
ha insegnato
che bisogna
fare un po'
attenzione
perché se
sbarchi
in terra santa
ti trovi
da una parte
tutto il mondo
arabo a nord
la siria
l'iraq
e dall'altra parte
ti trovi
l'egitto
e da lì
il nemico
arriva
da tutte le parti
perciò
da parecchio tempo
stanno cominciando
a pensare
che una vera
una spedizione
che debba avere successo
va studiata
in un altro modo
non si va
in terra santa
direttamente
si va in egitto
perché se si prende
l'egitto
e le sue grandi città
il cairo
alessandria
soprattutto
avremo un grande
porto a disposizione
e soprattutto
spezziamo in due
il mondo musulmano
e una volta
che ci siamo
stabiliti
in egitto
andare a gerusalemme
è molto più facile
quindi l'accordo
è andare
in egitto
non sono solo
ragioni strategiche
i veneziani
hanno in mente
anche qualcos'altro
l'egitto
è un grandissimo
hub commerciale
ad alessandria
ed egitto
arrivano le carovane
dalla cina
dall'india
con le spezie
con la sede
dal mar rosso
è uno dei grandi
porti del mediterraneo
e naturalmente
con alessandria
ed egitto
si commercia
in teoria
sarebbe vietato
commerciare
con gli infedeli
lo ha stabilito
il terzo concilio
lateranense
ma
lo fanno tutti
lo stesso
naturalmente
come tutte le cose
che la chiesa
vietava
tutti le facevano
lo stesso
facendo un po'
più attenzione
o tutt'al più
chiedevi
al papa
un'esenzione
i veneziani
da poco tempo
hanno ottenuto
dal papa
il permesso
di commerciare
con l'egitto
sembrano le cose
attuali di oggi
purché non esportassero
materiale bellico
armi
metallo
niente
per il resto
commerciate pure
il petrolio
appunto
quello
il gas
quello lì
gira lo stesso
dopodiché
ad alessandria
ed egitto
i veneziani
subivano
la concorrenza
dei genovesi
dei pisani
per cui
l'idea
se ce la conquistassimo
noi
alessandria
tutto sommato
potrebbe valerne
la pena
dunque
gli ambasciatori
tornano da venezia
tutti contenti
l'accordo è fatto
l'anticipo è pagato
arrivano a casa
e lì
trovano una doccia fredda
il conte di champagne
che era il primo
e il più potente
dei principi
che avevano preso
la croce
e che aveva
22 anni
si ammala
e muore
all'improvviso
erano tutti
d'accordo
che lui
sarebbe stato
simbolicamente
il capo
della crociata
in realtà
anche qui
capiamoci
una spedizione
come questa
non ha mai
un capo
nel nostro
senso moderno
ogni principe
che è lì
con i suoi vassalli
fa quello
che vuole lui
e tutt'al più
accetta
di partecipare
a un consiglio
di guerra
in cui insieme
decidiamo
cosa fare
però
nominalmente
un'autorità
è di moda
nominarla
doveva essere
il conte di champagne
chi lo fa adesso
non riescono
a mettersi
d'accordo
e a un certo punto
salta fuori
un nome
Villarduen
dice che è lui
che lo ha suggerito
il marchese
Bonifacio
di Monferrato
e quindi
un italiano
anzi
un lombardo
come avrebbero
detto loro
non un francese
però un grande
principe
uno dei grandi
principi europei
membro
di una famiglia
che da tanto
tempo
ha un rapporto
molto forte
con l'impresa
delle crociate
e col regno
di Gerusalemme
il papà
del marchese
Bonifacio
il marchese
Guglielmo
il vecchio
era stato
catturato
dal Saladino
all'epoca
in cui Saladino
conquistò
Gerusalemme
il figlio
del vecchio
marchese
fratello
maggiore
di Bonifacio
Corrado
marchese
di Monferrato
era arrivato
in terra
santa
rocambolescamente
era riuscito
a prendere
il comando
delle forze
crociate
residue
superstiti
dopo la sconfitta
inflitta
dal Saladino
aveva difeso
eroicamente
contro il Saladino
il porto
di tiro
garantendo
quindi ancora
una volta
ai crociati
il collegamento
marittimo
con la madrepatria
il Saladino
aveva assediato
tiro
difesa
da Corrado
di Monferrato
senza riuscire
a prenderla
a un certo punto
il Saladino
sperando di convincere
Corrado
ad arrendersi
fa portare
sotto le mura
di tiro
suo padre
il vecchio
marchese
Guglielmo
minacciando
di giustiziarlo
se Corrado
non cederà
la città
il marchese
Corrado
dalle mura
risponde
mio padre
ha già vissuto
abbastanza
a questo punto
naturalmente
il Saladino
non fa giustiziare
il vecchio marchese
anzi lo rimanda
a casa
con tanti saluti
però comunque
fatto sta
Corrado
è l'eroe
della crociata
viene eletto
dai baroni
re di Gerusalemme
poche ore dopo
viene assassinato
a pugnalate
in una via
di Gerusalemme
non si sa mai
saputo da chi
il fratello minore
Bonifacio
è quello
a cui adesso
i baroni
francesi
vanno a proporre
di capeggiare
la crociata
a noi
verrebbe da pensare
che magari
la terra santa
in Monferrato
non portava
tanto bene
ma avete già capito
che loro ragionavano
in un altro modo
Bonifacio
accetta
di corsa
e a questo punto
abbiamo tutto
abbiamo il trasporto
abbiamo l'accordo
con i veneziali
abbiamo l'appuntamento
primavera del 2002
ci troviamo tutti
a Venezia
e nella primavera
del 2002
i crociati
cominciano a partire
dalla Francia del nord
e affluiscono
verso Venezia
lì cominciano
a venire fuori
le prime grane
perché non sono tutti
d'accordo
che sia una buona idea
partire da Venezia
c'è gente
che preferisce
partire da Marsiglia
c'è gente
che non vuole partire
con il grosso
vuole partire
per conto suo
però insomma
la maggior parte
arrivano a Venezia
uno di quelli
che ci arrivano
è il secondo
dei nostri testimoni
non è un grande barone
come Geoffroy de Villardouin
uno dei capi
della crociata
di quelli che fanno
i negoziati
e che conoscono
i segreti
no
il secondo testimone
che si chiama Robert
Roberto Clarit
è un cavaliere
un cavaliere qualunque
un cavaliere povero
come dice lui
perché lui
il mondo aristocratico
lo vede diviso in due
ci sono i gran signori
che lui
nel suo dialetto
della Francia del Nord
chiama
i ricche homme
i ricchi
e poi ci siamo noi
i loro vassalli
i poveri cavalieri
ecco
ovviamente capite
un cavaliere
in quella società
è comunque un signore
per i contadini
un cavaliere
è uno di quelli
che comandano
ma rispetto ai principi
ai grandi baroni
un cavaliere
come Robert de Clarit
si sente
una persona normale
una persona qualunque
i grandi baroni
Villardouin
l'ha già vista
Venezia
è andato a negoziare
col Doge
Robert de Clarit
ci arriva
nella primavera
del 2002
non l'ha mai vista
in vita sua
e qui viene fuori
come dire
sapete qual è il motivo
per cui io vi racconto
stasera questa lunga storia
è che il tema
del festival
di quest'anno
è la meraviglia
e allora
la meraviglia
è il filo conduttore
delle memorie
di questi uomini
che hanno visto
Costantinopoli
e che prima di Costantinopoli
hanno visto Venezia
e già quella cosa lì
è bastata per sbigottili
Roberto de Clarit
arriva a Venezia
e lo racconta
tutte queste navi
navi di tanti tipi diversi
usa tutti i termini tecnici
i dromoni
gli usceri
quando i pellegrini
furono tutti riuniti
a Venezia
e videro
la potente flotta
che era stata fatta
le ricche navi
i grandi dromoni
e gli usceri
per portare i cavalli
e le galere
si meravigliarono
molto
ed è la grande
ricchezza
che trovarono
nella città
ora Venezia
è una grandissima città
ma i pellegrini
sono tanti
migliaia
in città
non trovano posto
li sbattono tutti
al Lido
ad accamparsi
sotto le tende
al Lido
di Venezia
e la flotta
è pronta
e la costruzione
della flotta
è stata un'impresa
colossale
e adesso
che i pellegrini
sono arrivati
il Doge
presenta
il conto
e qui
cominciano i guai
perché
l'accordo
era per trasportare
4.500
cavalieri
e invece
loro sono stati
molto ottimisti
Villarduen
dice
è per colpa
di tutti
quei bastardi
che sono andati
a imbarcarsi
da altre parti
perché se venivano
tutti a Venezia
come si era deciso
non c'era problema
ma invece sono
fatto sta
che a Venezia
invece di 4.500
cavalieri
ce ne sono solo
mille
e gente a piedi
in proporzione
ma il Doge
vuole essere pagato
questo è un contratto
ragazzi
avete firmato
e quindi la somma
è quella
allora i crociati
si tassano
ogni cavaliere
invece di due
marchi ne tira fuori
quattro
più quattro
per il cavallo
anche ai poveri
vanno a far
tirar fuori i soldi
un Marco
a testa
anche i più poveri
fanno il conto
mancano ancora
50.000
marchi
più di metà
del totale
e il Doge
comincia a essere
leggermente
innervosito
dice Clarie
il Doge
ci ha fatto
il seguente discorso
signori
ci avete messi
nei guai
perché io
ho ordinato
in tutto il mio paese
che nessun mercante
andasse a commerciare
e che tutti
aiutassero
a radunare
questa flotta
e ci hanno tutti
lavorato
e non hanno guadagnato
niente per un anno
e mezzo
anzi hanno speso
molto
e perciò
i miei uomini
e anch'io
vogliamo che
paghiate i denari
che ci dovete
e se non lo fate
sappiate che non
vi muoverete
da quest'isola
sono tutti al Lido
prima di averci pagati
e non troverete
chi vi porti
da bere
e da mangiare
in realtà
Robert de Clarie
aggiunge
il Doge
era una persona
per bene
non ha mica impedito
che ci portassero
da bere
e da mangiare
dopodichè
fanno un'altra colletta
tirano fuori
tutto quello
che hanno ancora
nella borsa
prendono in prestito
tutto quello
che possono
pagano
mancano ancora
36.000 marchi
a questo punto
il Doge
propone
la soluzione
e dice
guardate ragazzi
noi per puro caso
ci stavamo preparando
a fare una piccola spedizione
ci sarebbe una città
qui vicino
in Dalmazia
si chiama Zara
che in passato
ubbidiva a noi
e adesso invece
si è ribellata
non ci vuole più ubbidire
si è messa sotto la protezione
del re d'Ungheria
e noi stiamo per partire
per andarcela
a riprendere
questa città
se voi ci accompagnate
a conquistare
Zara
faremo di sicuro
molto bottino
con la vostra parte
del bottino
pagate il biglietto
e a quel punto
vi portiamo in Egitto
e i capi
dei crociati
si trovano davanti
all'alternativa
che poi continuerà
a ossessionarli
per tutto il resto
della crociata
e cioè
ci sono quelli
che dicono
ma noi non siamo mica
venuti per fare
una roba del genere
no
e ci sono quelli
la maggioranza
che hanno
la sindrome
che
non si può permettere
che l'impresa fallisca
è uno sforzo
talmente enorme
abbiamo messo insieme
un tale esercito
e lasciamo
tutto andare a male
perché mancano
un po' di soldi
no
la priorità
assoluta
è che la crociata
vada avanti
e se per andare avanti
dobbiamo fare
degli accordi
con i veneziani
li facciamo
e quelli che non sono
d'accordo
sono dei traditori
Villardueng
è di questi
che vede
traditori
dappertutto
tutti quelli
che dicono
ma veramente
io mi sono impegnato
ad andare a Gerusalemme
mica andare a Zara
per lui
sono dei traditori
che non vogliono
che la crociata
abbia successo
c'è anche un legato papale
che accompagna
la spedizione
e il legato papale
garantisce
che il papa
se lo sapesse
sarebbe d'accordo
anche lui
la cosa più importante
è che la spedizione
non fallisca
quindi assolutamente
andate avanti
in effetti
la cosa è un po' grossa
la città di Zara
cristiana
si è messa
sotto la protezione
del re d'Ungheria
che non solo è cristiano
ma ha anche preso
la croce
anche lui
e tuttavia
alla fine
la maggioranza
dei capi
decide di accettare
l'offerta
dei veneziani
dice Roberto Clarit
il cavaliere povero
ma tutti quelli
dell'esercito
non seppero mica
di questa decisione
tranne i capi
più importanti
a questo punto
torna sulla scena
il doge
che fa un grande
colpo di teatro
abbiamo già detto
che 50 galere veneziane
si uniranno
comunque alla crociata
con i loro equipaggi
quindi un gran numero
di veneziani
partiranno
anche loro
ad accompagnare
i crociati
il doge
riunisce
in San Marco
tutti i veneziani
che devono partire
insieme ai crociati
sale sul pulpito
e parla al popolo
signori
siete in compagnia
della miglior gente
del mondo
e per la più alta
impresa
che mai qualcuno
abbia affrontato
e io sono
un uomo vecchio
e debole
e avrei bisogno
di riposo
e sono mutilato
nel corpo
e cieco
ma vedo
che nessuno di voi
saprebbe governare
e comandare
come me
se volete
concedervi
che io
prenda
il segno
della croce
per accompagnarvi
e istruirvi
e mio figlio
rimanga al mio posto
a difendere
la città
io andrei
a vivere
e morire
con voi
e con i pellegrini
e naturalmente
tutti si mettono
a piangere
e tutti gridano
sì sì
vai vai
e il doge
prende la croce
e partirà
alla testa
del contingente
veneziano
dice Villarduen
che è entusiasta
chiaramente
di questa cosa
quel valoroso
avrebbe avuto
tutta la possibilità
di restare a casa
perché era
un uomo vecchio
e aveva gli occhi
nella testa
belli
eppure non vedeva
niente
che aveva perduto
la vista
per una ferita
che aveva avuto
la testa
era di gran cuore
come gli assomigliavano
poco
quelli che erano
andati ad altri porti
per schivare
il pericolo
e dunque
la flotta
salpa
e qui non ve la faccio
lunga
ma meriterebbe
di leggere
tutto il resoconto
che fa Robert de Clary
che su quella flotta
si è imbarcato
dello spettacolo
meraviglioso
di nuovo
loro hanno
in realtà
ecco
in cose diverse
la guerra medievale
dalla nostra
e che loro
ci vedono
la bellezza
c'è un senso estetico
fortissimo
una flotta
che parte
con tutti i pennoni
le bandiere
tutto pitturato
tutto colorato
gli stemmi
le bande che suonano
le trombe
i tamburi
il clero
che canta
veni
creator spiritus
essere a bordo
di quella flotta
è un'esperienza
anche solo
vederla partire
è un'esperienza
indimenticabile
e quindi partono
non ve la faccio lunga
arrivano a Zara
la prendono
la saccheggiano
spartiscono
il bottino
dopodichè
i veneziani
dicono
sapete che ormai
è un po' tardi
per andare fino
in Egitto
magari è meglio
se ci fermiamo qua
sverniamo
e poi
la primavera
prossima
andiamo tutti
in Egitto
intanto
tocca fare
anche una cosa
un po' spiacevole
e cioè
devono scrivere
al Papa
per raccontargli
quello che hanno fatto
e scrivono
e il Papa
non è contento
per niente
e gli scrive
che hanno fatto
malissimo
a fare questa cosa
ma comunque
li assolve
perché non lo facciano
più
e si guardino
bene
dall'attaccare
altri cristiani
e quindi loro
è vero
è che d'inverno
non si navigano
nel Mediterraneo
ovviamente
si sta a casa
quindi loro passano
l'inverno lì
e nel dicembre
del 1202
arriva a Zara
il Marchese Bonifacio
di Monferrato
finalmente
a prendere
il comando
dell'esercito
e con lui
arriva
un personaggio
esotico
perché il Marchese Bonifacio
prima di partire
è andato in Germania
a salutare
l'imperatore
il suo signore
e a Natale
alla corte
dell'imperatore
ha incontrato
un giovane principe
che veniva
da Costantinopoli
da Bisanzio
da un mondo
al tempo stesso
molto vicino
e
incredibilmente
lontano
da Costantinopoli
era arrivato
in Germania
un giovane principe
si chiamava
Alessio Angelo
figlio
dell'imperatore
Isacco II
il giovane principe
è scappato
da Costantinopoli
in incognito
ed è venuto
in occidente
a chiedere aiuto
perché suo padre
è stato deposto
da un colpo di stato
il colpo di stato
lo ha fatto lo zio
il fratello di Isacco
lo ha deposto
lo ha accecato
e ha preso il potere
il figlio
Alessio
è riuscito a scappare
e adesso
viene a chiedere aiuto
arriva quindi
dall'impero bizantino
ora voi
immaginate
che cos'è
l'impero bizantino
in quel momento
non è più
un impero
immenso
però comunque
vuol sempre dire
i Balcani
un bel pezzo
di Asia Minore
Creta
Cipro
e l'immensa capitale
Costantinopoli
è un impero
dove parlano greco
che in occidente
nessuno capisce
il fatto che loro
parlano greco
detto fra parentesi
vuole anche dire
che leggono
Omero
nel testo originale
che leggono
i tragici greci
cioè roba che in occidente
nessuno sapeva neanche
che esistessero
invece i bizantini
leggono Eschilo
e Euripide
e parlano greco
infatti i nostri
occidentali
li chiamano
i greci
ma loro
gli abitanti
dell'impero bizantino
non pensano
di essere greci
loro pensano
di essere i romani
perché quello
è l'impero romano
d'oriente
che ha sempre
continuato
senza nessuna
interruzione
dai tempi
di Costantino
con la sua capitale
a Costantinopoli
loro parlano greco
e in greco
dicono noi
i romani
che siano romani
in occidente
non ci crede nessuno
i romani
siamo noi
che abbiamo Roma
e che parliamo latino
ma invece
i greci
di Costantinopoli
si sentono
i veri romani
e sono cristiani
naturalmente
però sono un po'
diversi
soprattutto
perché non
riconoscono
l'autorità
del papa
e questa cosa
in occidente
brucia
sono fratelli
cristiani
anche loro
però
però sono fratelli
che sbagliano
e sbagliano
molto
ecco
vivono in questo
impero
che rispetto
all'occidente
che è tutto diviso
regni
contè
principati
comuni
indipendenti
mille poteri
in concorrenza
fra loro
e invece
l'impero bizantino
è un impero
follemente
centralizzato
governato
da un imperatore
con pieni poteri
fino al prossimo
colpo di stato
una poderosa
burocrazia
un'economia
statalista
in cui a nessuno
viene permesso
fare troppi profitti
e lo stato
controlla
tutta l'economia
mentre nelle città
come Venezia
c'è il capitalismo
selvaggio
e infatti
non per niente
i mercanti italiani
già a quest'epoca
si stanno mangiando
l'economia
dell'impero bizantino
perché l'impero bizantino
con suo sistema centralizzato
non regge
alla concorrenza
dei mercanti italiani
chi conosce
quel mondo
lo conoscono
appunto i mercanti
Costantinopoli
è piena di veneziani
di genovesi
di pisani
e poi lo conoscono
i sovrani
perché a livello
di sovrani
si negozia
con i bizantini
e ci si scambia
anche alleanze
e matrimoni
perché Alessio
da Costantinopoli
è arrivato
in Germania
a chiedere aiuto
perché l'imperatore
ha sposato
sua sorella
e perché Bonifacio
se lo porta dietro
quando va a Zara
a prendere il comando
dell'esercito crociato
perché sono parenti
anche loro
il fratello maggiore
di Bonifacio
Corrado
aveva sposato
la zia di Alessio
a quel livello
il mondo
dei regnanti
è unico
tutto legato
quindi Bonifacio
si porta dietro
a Zara
il giovane
Alessio Angelo
il quale
ha da fare
ai crociati
e ai veneziani
una di quelle proposte
che è difficile rifiutare
e cioè
dice
voi capite
lo zio
cattivo
ha esautorato
mio padre
torniamo
aiutatemi
a riprendere il trono
a punire l'usurpatore
a difendere
i miei legittimi diritti
davanti a Dio
e io mi impegno
a finanziare
la crociata
con un enorme contributo
fissano le cifre
naturalmente
ecco
non solo
Alessio si impegna
sapendo qual è
l'altro punto debole
oltre ai soldi
io mi impegno
a riportare
la chiesa greca
all'obbedienza
di Roma
se voi vi aiutate
a riprendere il trono
fa queste promesse
colossali
non è ben chiaro
quanto siano rimasti
sorpresi
i capi dei crociati
anzi
a dire la verità
è probabile
che questa cosa
fosse già nell'aria
che l'avessero capito
che si materializzava
questa offerta
i veneziani
hanno una gran voglia
di accettare
perché
come dire
Costantinopoli
è l'altro grande
hub commerciale
oltre Alessandria
d'Egitto
lì c'è da fare
profitti commerciali
colossali
e i veneziani
a Costantinopoli
per tanto tempo
hanno avuto
tutti i privilegi
commerciali
e invece
gli ultimi
imperatori
favoriscono
i genovesi
i pisani
e i veneziani
i veneziani
rosicano
e qui entra in scena
se volete
il nostro terzo
protagonista
vi ho parlato
di due dei crociati
Geoffroy de Villardouin
il grande barone
Roberto Clarit
il cavaliere povero
ma il terzo testimone
è un greco
o meglio
è un romano
come diceva lui
è un grande funzionario
dell'impero bizantino
un ministro
un personaggio
di altissimo livello
si chiama Niceta
Niceta coniata
e Niceta
che è un ministro
dell'imperatore
racconta anche lui
questa storia
adesso entra anche
la sua voce
racconta come Alessio
è andato dai veneziani
a fare queste proposte
ma Niceta
Niceta è convinto
che sono i veneziani
che hanno macchinato
tutto
Alessio
è un burattino
l'animaccia nera
di tutta questa storia
è il doge
Enrico Dandolo
che ai crociati
sembrava un grande eroe
Niceta
di questo
che lui chiama
il dux veneticon
ericos dandulos
ha un'idea
abbastanza diversa
un uomo
privo degli occhi
e molto in là
con gli anni
ma un invidioso
che odiava
i romani
un astuto impostore
che proclamava
di essere tanto saggio
e non vedeva l'ora
di farla pagare
ai romani
insomma
secondo Niceta
coniata
sono i veneziani
che si sono approfittati
di Alessio
era un ragazzino
non sapeva mica
cosa prometteva
gli hanno fatto firmare
tutto quello che volevano
dice Niceta
testualmente
un mare di soldi
che non aveva
e poi
questa vergogna
ecco
Alessio ha promesso
con grande leggerezza
per la società
bizantina
tornare
all'obbedienza
di Roma
è una vergogna
intollerabile
perché Roma
ha torto
e siamo noi
che abbiamo ragione
tornare all'obbedienza
di Roma
soltanto un ragazzino
mentecato
che si fa manovrare
dagli stranieri
può aver promesso
una cosa simile
rinunciare
alla fede
dei nostri padri
per obbedire
a quelli
dice Niceta
di Roma
vecchia
perché Costantinopoli
è Roma
naturalmente
la Roma nuova
quella dei papi
è la Roma
vecchia
sprofondata
nel peccato
e nell'errore
come potete
bene immaginare
la proposta
di Alessio
viene discussa
tra pochi
come dire
ammessi al segreto
fra i capi
fra i baroni
Villardueng
c'è naturalmente
discutono
e ovviamente
ci sono quelli
che non sono d'accordo
perché si trattava
di attaccare
dei cristiani
e loro non erano
partiti per questo
anzi
volevano andare
in Palestina
e l'altra parte
dice Villardueng
gli rispondeva
bei signori
in Palestina
non combinerete
niente
bei signori
è normale
biau signor
fra gentiluoni
fra cavalieri
fra baroni
in antico francese
ci si rivolge
così agli altri
biau signor
bei signori
non combinerete
niente
volete andare
a crepare
di fame laggiù
non abbiamo soldi
non abbiamo viveri
i veneziani
e Alessio
ci promettono
tutto
andiamo
rimettiamo sul trono
il ragazzino
che ha tutti i diritti
Dio sarà contento
e poi finalmente
partiremo per l'Egitto
alla fine
quelli che non sono
d'accordo
se ne vanno
e gli altri
decidono di andare
a Costantinopoli
e solo a questo punto
dice Roberto
e Clary
ce l'hanno raccontato
anche a noi
hanno deciso
tutto fra i capi
poi finalmente
l'hanno raccontato
anche a noi
e a quel punto
hanno fatto venire
avanti i vescovi
e i vescovi
e gli abbiamo chiesto
se era un peccato
fare questa cosa
di andare a Costantinopoli
e i vescovi
risposero
che non era mica
peccato
anzi
era una grande
opera buona
perché noi
avevamo
il legittimo
erede
che era stato
diseredato
ed era sacrosanto
aiutarlo
a difendere
i suoi diritti
e quindi
arrivata
la primavera
del 2004
salpano
da Zara
toccano
Corfu
vari altri posti
alla fine
di giugno
prendono terra
sulla costa
asiatica
davanti a
Costantinopoli
e qui di nuovo
come dire
spalancano gli occhi
quasi nessuno
di loro
ha mai visto
una città così
Villarduén
ora potete sapere
che guardarono
molto
Costantinopoli
quelli che non
l'avevano ancora
mai vista
che non potevano
mica credere
che in tutto il mondo
ci potesse essere
una città
così forte
e sappiate
che non ci fu
nessuno
così coraggioso
che la carne
non gli fremesse
e non c'era
da stupirsi
perché un'impresa
così importante
non è mai stata
affrontata
da nessuno
dopo che il mondo
fu creato
naturalmente
Villarduén
scrive dopo
quando ormai
è tutto fatto
e loro hanno costruito
questa interpretazione
di quello che loro
hanno fatto
la più grande
impresa
che il mondo
abbia mai visto
e dunque
la meraviglia
dei crociati
che arrivano
sotto questa
immensa metropoli
ma Roberto
Clary
dice anche
la meraviglia
degli abitanti
di Costantinopoli
che vedono
arrivare
questa enorme
flotta
erano montati
sulle mura
e sui tetti
delle case
per guardare
quella
meraviglia
naturalmente
mentre i crociati
guardavano
Costantinopoli
e probabilmente
erano divisi
fra
il dirsi
eh
sarà mica
tanto facile
riuscire a prenderlo
effettivamente
e il dirsi
ma pensate
alle ricchezze
che ci sono dentro
e i greci
che dalle mura
guardano fuori
quello che vedono
arrivare
è un'immensa
flotta
di barbari
che vengono
dall'occidente
da quell'occidente
da cui non viene
mai niente di buono
i barbari
gli occidentali
sono barbari
e sono occidentali
Niceta li chiama
proprio così
eh
quando parla di loro
li chiama a volte
i latini
noi siamo i greci
loro sono i latini
ma più spesso
Niceta dice
quelli dell'occidente
e questi dell'occidente
sono brutta gente
sono gente strana
sono diversi
anche fisicamente
dai romani
di Costantinopoli
perché i romani
portano la barba
e Niceta invece
dice
questi qua
si radono la barba
in Europa
a quell'epoca
la barba non era di moda
non la portava nessuno
e Niceta dice
sembrano sempre giovani
con le guance rasate
in questo modo
rispetto a noi
ecco
e Niceta
dà anche la data
dell'arrivo
dei crociati
era l'inizio
del mese di luglio
del 6711
perché a Costantinopoli
non contano gli anni
dalla nascita di Cristo
ma li contano
dalla creazione
del mondo
e i loro dotti
studiando la Bibbia
hanno calcolato
quanto tempo è passato
dalla creazione
del mondo
e quindi il loro calendario
va avanti
da allora
adesso sono
nel 6700
ecco
pensate
una civiltà
che sa di vivere
nell'anno
bene
i crociati
sono arrivati
e sperano ancora
che il ragazzino
Alessio
il quale ha promesso
Mario Monti
dice
sono tutti a favore
appena arriviamo a noi
ci apriranno le porte
quindi i crociati
mettono Alessio
su una barca
e lo portano
sotto le mura
sperando che la gente
lo riconosca
non lo riconosce nessuno
grande delusione
e quindi
toccherà
assediare la città
intanto
dentro la città
lo zio
usurpatore
ve l'ho già detto
che si chiama
Alessio anche lui
e vabbè
è diventato
l'imperatore
Alessio III
lo zio
usurpatore
che finora
non ci credeva mica
che arrivavano davvero
i latini
quando gliene parlavano
pensava che fosse
una barzelletta
dice Niceta
non aveva fatto
nessun preparativo
adesso che sono arrivati
comincia a darsi una mossa
va a vedere
la situazione
della flotta
scopre che l'intera flotta
dell'impero bizantino
comprende
venti barche
marcite
e mangiate dai vermi
non abbiamo
una flotta
la difesa principale
della città
ci sono naturalmente
truppe greche
cavalleria greca
ma la vera forza
capace di difendere
la città
sono i variaghi
sono i mercenari
norvegesi
danesi
inglesi
che da secoli
gli imperatori bizantini
fanno venire dal nord
da secoli
i vichinghi
sanno
che se uno vuol fare carriera
e guadagnare un sacco
di monete d'oro
deve andare a sud
deve andare a Costantinopoli
lì l'imperatore
paga bene
e i variaghi
che Niceta
chiama anche
i barbari
armati di scure
sono questa forza
appunto
corazzata
a piedi
armati
di queste grandi scuri
e loro sono
i principali difensori
della città
poi a difendere
la città
ci sarebbero anche
quelli di Pisa
perché essendo nemici
dei veneziani
se i veneziani
sono contro
quelli di Pisa
sono a favore
i pisani
fanno affari
con Costantinopoli
c'è una colonia
pisana in città
e si prepara
ad aiutare
i greci
a difendere
la città
e finalmente
i crociati
danno l'assalto
alle mura
e qui
qui capite
è proprio come
nei film
anche se sembra
incredibile
è come nei film
c'è questa città
sul mare
una parte
delle mura
danno direttamente
sul mare
lì si va sotto
con le galere
cercando di drizzare
dalle galere
delle scale
e dove c'è
un po' di spiaggia
si cerca di prendere
terra sulla spiaggia
e anche lì
scale
appoggiare le scale
ai muri
e arrampicarsi su
come nei film
o nei videogiochi
da su ti tirano
addosso la pece bollente
ti tirano i sassi
dalle galere
si tira
con gli archi
con le balestre
per cercare di allontanare
i difensori
dalle mura
i cavalieri
salgono sulle scale
sopra ci sono
i danesi
con le asce
che cercano
di tirarli giù
si tenta
non si riesce
e a questo punto
il doge
prende di nuovo
l'iniziativa
con grande entusiasmo
di Villarduain
e ora potrete udire
una straordinaria
prodezza
perché il doge
di Venezia
che era un vecchio
e non vedeva
niente
era tutto
armato
alla prua
della sua galea
col gonfalone
di San Marco
davanti a lui
e gridava
ai suoi
che lo mettessero
a terra
altrimenti
li avrebbe fatti
giustiziare
e così fecero
che la galea
prende terra
e saltano fuori
e portano
il gonfalone
di San Marco
a terra
davanti a lui
e sbarcano
e dopo un attimo
non si capisce
come il gonfalone
di San Marco
è su una delle torri
poi però
lì i veneziani
si fermano
perché non osano
andare avanti
e a questo punto
l'imperatore Alessio
che è dentro
e che non è un soldato
è costretto
a furor di popolo
a fare qualcosa
il popolo
comincia a essere
seriamente spaventato
Alessio
prende la testa
delle sue truppe greche
esce in massa
dalla città
per affrontare
i crociati
e qui questa storia
ce la racconta
Roberto Clarice
che era lì
era uno dei cavalieri
che
quando vedono
che arriva
il nemico
e viene sotto
devono decidere
cosa fare
tutto l'esercito
dei cavalieri
è organizzato
in sette reparti
voi capite
un signore
un gran signore
col suo stendardo
con i suoi vassalli
quanti siamo
dieci
quindici
un altro gran signore
con i suoi vassalli
fra tutti
un centinaio di cavalieri
alcune bandiere
formiamo un reparto
il conte di Fiandra
un reparto
il conte di Champagne
decidono
qui bisogna difendere
l'accampamento
la maggior parte
rimanga a difendere
l'accampamento
quattro dei reparti
altri tre reparti
invece
vanno incontro
al nemico
dice Roberto
e Clary
organizzazione ferrea
ogni reparto
aveva due comandanti
che stabilivano
se bisognava fermarsi
andare al passo
oppure caricare
e abbiamo cominciato
a muoverci
perché lui era lì
nel secondo
di questi tre reparti
che cominciano
ad andare avanti
al passo
verso l'imperatore
che è uscito
dalla città
con tutte le sue truppe
lui era lì
nel secondo
di questi reparti
il primo
c'era il conte di Fiandra
che aveva chiesto
l'onore
di avere
l'avanguardia
perché come sempre
in questi casi
quello che si fa
è per far vedere
chi sei
e per guadagnarti gloria
oltre che bottino
dopo naturalmente
e dunque
l'avanguardia
ovviamente è il posto
più pericoloso
prima di cominciare
c'è tutto il tempo
di cominciare
naturalmente
si discute
chi va per primo
vado io
va bene
e il conte di Fiandra
non puoi dirgli no
il conte di Fiandra
va avanti a tutti
dietro c'è l'altro battaglione
l'altro scaglione
dove c'è dentro
Robert de Clary
con il suo signore
Messer Pierre Damien
di Amien
che Robert de Clary
non menziona mai
senza dire
l'ibiaus
e l'iprus
il bello
e prode
Messer Pierre Damien
il mio signore
e io ero lì con lui
siamo al secondo posto
e poi a un certo punto
i consiglieri
del conte di Fiandra
gli dicono
ma sarà prudente
andare incontro
al nemico
ma non sarebbe meglio
tornare indietro
e restare fermi
vicino all'accampamento
perché lì combattiamo meglio
e abbiamo tutti i nostri
dietro che ci possono aiutare
sì sì dai
è meglio
torniamo indietro
e il primo scaglione
al comando del conte di Fiandra
comincia a tornare indietro
e quelli del secondo scaglione
dove c'è Robert de Clary
con il suo signore
vedono
il primo scaglione
che torna indietro
e si fermano
cito da Robert de Clary
che era lì
e che ha vissuto
la giornata
la giornata della sua vita
quella volta
e tutti dicono
tutti insieme
che il conte di Fiandra
faceva una cosa vergognosa
che tornava indietro
pur avendo l'avanguardia
e dicono tutti insieme
Sire
il conte di Fiandra
torna indietro
visto che torna indietro
vi lascia l'avanguardia
prendiamola
in nome di Dio
intanto il conte di Fiandra
torna indietro
si accorge che loro
sono rimasti fermi
gli manda un messaggio
dicendo per piacere
tornate indietro anche voi
e Messire Pierre Damien
gli risponde
che non ritorneranno
affatto
ma questo ve lo devo dire
nel francese antico
di Robert de Clary
e Messire Pierre Damien
li remanda
e il conte di Fiandra
gli manda altri messaggeri
per dire
che per Dio
non gli facciano
questa vergogna
e che tornino indietro
anche loro
che lui è tornato
perché gli hanno consigliato
di farlo
ma loro rifiutano
e Pierre Damien
comanda
signori
cavalcate
in nome di Dio
al passo
e tutti quelli
che erano rimasti indietro
cominciarono a gridare
guardate
il conte di San Paul
e Messire Pierre Damien
vanno a combattere
l'imperatore
signore
i Dio
cominciarono a dire
e a gridare
signore i Dio
proteggete
oggi loro
e tutta la loro compagnia
guardate
hanno l'avanguardia
che il conte di Fiandra
doveva avere
dopodiché
Robert de Clary
che era lì
e che io non so
se ha avuto tempo
di alzare gli occhi
verso la città
magari l'ha anche avuto
ma dopo
quando si ricorda
questa cosa
se lo ricorda benissimo
che mentre noi
eravamo lì
andavamo avanti
verso il nemico
e avevamo
l'avanguardia
tutte le donne
e le ragazze
della città
erano lì
alle finestre
che ci guardavano
e questa è la cosa
formidabile
noi eravamo lì
bellissimi
e le ragazze
ci guardavano
le dame
le damigelle
del palazzo
e quelle del popolo
sulle mura
e dicevano
fra loro
che i nostri
sembravano angeli
tanto erano belli
chi gliel'abbia poi
raccontato
a Robert de Clary
che le ragazze greche
però insomma
lui
quella cosa lì
è sicuro
eravamo belli
accidenti
se eravamo belli
tanto che il conte
di Fiandra
per la vergogna
torna indietro
li raggiunge
a quel punto
vanno avanti
alla pari
perché nessuno
vuole cedere
vanno avanti
e l'imperatore
Alessio
si spaventa
volta le spalle
e torna
in città
con tutta
la sua gente
e loro
rimangono fuori
padroni del campo
senza aver dovuto
dare una botta
di spada
Villardouin
che qui è un po'
più freddo
di Robert de Clary
commenta
e sappiate
che non ci fu
nessuno
così coraggioso
da non essere
molto contento
in altre parole
nessuno ha detto
era meglio
se restavano fuori
che combattevamo
no no
benissimo così
sono tornati dentro
abbiamo vinto
senza combattere
e a questo punto
però Alessio
è finito
perché il popolo
della città
non riconosce più
la sua autorità
non ha avuto
il coraggio
di affrontare
i barbari
invasori
e scappa
Alessio III
sale in barca
col suo tesoro
e lascia
la città
di nascosto
Niceta
coniata
che era stato
suo ministro
commenta
questa fuga
di Alessio
anzi come dire
fa un ritrattino
dell'usurpatore
che è scappato
dice
vabbè
era un gran vigliacco
ma non era
cattivo
era una persona
piacevole
con cui si poteva
discutere
non faceva
inchiodare
gli occhi
o tagliare
le mani
e i piedi
dice Niceta
trasformandosi
in cuoco
di uomini
ecco
un imperatore
bizantino
è uno che cucina
gli uomini
quelli che gli dispiacciono
gli oppositori
gli avversari
lui no
lui era una persona
per bene
tutto sommato
ma era un usurpatore
e aveva la coscienza
sporca
temeva la giustizia
di Dio
era sempre inquieto
angosciato
a questo punto
Costantinopoli
si sveglia
senza un imperatore
chi prende in mano
la situazione
gli eunuchi
di palazzo
e le guardie
armate
di scure
i variaghi
danesi
e inglesi
che sono la principale
forza militare
si mettono d'accordo
che facciamo
rimettiamo sul trono
Isacco
lo andiamo a prendere
l'usurpatore
lo ha fatto accecare
pazienza
lo portano per mano
cieco com'è
lo rimettono
sul trono
e Isacco
dice
ma andate a chiamare
mio figlio
che è fuori
con i barbari
e quindi
mandano a chiamare
Alessio
Isacco
se lo associa
al trono
diventa
ovviamente
Alessio
quarto
ma i crociati
prima di lasciare
Alessio andare
lasciarlo rientrare
in città
si assicurano
che anche il padre
Isacco
confermi
tutti gli impegni
presi
i soldi
il sostegno
alla crociata
e così via
Isacco
firma tutto
Niceta
che è lì
e vede tutto
si mette le mani
nei capelli
per giorni e giorni
a palazzo
arrivavano questi capi
degli occidentali
si sedevano lì
in presenza
dell'imperatore
bisognava riceverli
tutti lì
a adularli
i nostri benefattori
i nostri salvatori
tutti a spendere
regali
banchetti
hanno svuotato
il tesoro imperiale
e per questi
barbari
non ce n'era mai
abbastanza
perché nessun
altro popolo
è più avido
di ricchezze
degli occidentali
oh
hanno preso
Costantinopoli
pacificamente
a questo punto
loro se ne stanno
alloggiati fuori
ma chi vuole
va a fare il turista
in città
è il momento
in cui davvero
dall'esercito crociato
un sacco di gente
scopre
per la prima volta
cos'è Costantinopoli
meraviglia generale
palazzi
chiese
reliquie di santi
è un momento
meraviglioso
ma non dura
perché il popolo
di Costantinopoli
sopporta male
questi stranieri
arroganti
che sono venuti
a comandare
a casa nostra
gli imperatori
li favoriscono
fanno malissimo
cominciano
gli scontri
le aggressioni
contro i turisti
occidentali
cominciano
gli incidenti
a un certo punto
i crociati
vengono a sapere
cosa incredibile
inaudita
che a Costantinopoli
c'è perfino
un quartiere musulmano
con una moschea
non è concepibile
procedono a fare
una spedizione punitiva
per andare a bruciare
la moschea
i musulmani
del luogo
si difendono
i greci cristiani
accorrono
in aiuto
dei vicini musulmani
e respingono
i crociati
nello scontro
scoppia un incendio
un enorme incendio
che devasta
una grossa parte
della città
bruciano
interi quartieri
brucia il foro
di Costantino
brucia parte
dell'ippodromo
bruciano chiese
palazzi
vie commerciali
piene di botteghe
moltissimi morti
moltissima
senza tetto
gente che ha perso tutto
per parecchi giorni
ci si può spostare
solo via mare
talmente l'infuoco
e il fumo
occupano la città
brucia anche la casa
di unicetta coniate
fra l'altro
il grande palazzo
che questo ministro
aveva
e intanto
i rapporti
fra la popolazione
locale
e i crociati
ormai
sono pessimi
e il giovane
Alessio
e suo padre
Isacco
decidono che
a questo punto
gli impegni
con i crociati
non li mantengono
anche perché
i soldi
non ci sono
comunque
e quindi
non pagano
i crociati
insistono
c'è il contratto
c'è l'accordo
niente
non pagano
mandano
un gruppetto
di ambasciatori
al palazzo
dell'imperatore
con l'incarico
di dirgli
che se non paga
loro
lo sfidano
e la pagherà
cara
questi ambasciatori
ci vanno
senza ben sapere
se torneranno indietro
tutti interi
e
Villarduen
che è lì
lo racconta
insomma ecco
ci hanno accolti
siamo arrivati
eravamo armati
siamo andati armati
siamo entrati
nella sala del trono
c'era lì
gli due imperatori
tutti i loro ministri
le guardie
gli abbiamo fatto
il nostro discorsetto
gli abbiamo detto
che se non pagavano
si considerassero
sfidati
poi ci siamo girati
siamo tornati indietro
per fortuna
nessuno
si è mosso
siamo tornati indietro
ma
non era mai successo
che nel palazzo
dell'imperatore
venissero degli stranieri
a sfidarlo
apertamente
e ne uscissero
ancora tutti intieri
Robert de Clary
sa anche
di un'altra cosa
gliel'hanno raccontata
questa non sarà vera
ma è verosimile
però
sa che anche il doge
ha avuto un dialogo
con il giovane Alessio
il giovane Alessio
sulla riva
a cavallo
il doge
sulla solita galera
e
il succo
del discorso
è che il doge
alla fine
ha detto
all'imperatore
cito testualmente
ragazzaccio
furfante
noi ti abbiamo
tirato fuori
dalla merda
e nella merda
ti rimetteremo
e a questo punto
i crociati
si preparano
a sediare
per la seconda volta
Costantinopoli
ma dentro
la città
il potere
degli imperatori
sta crollando
perché sono
impopolari
anche loro
intanto
il padre
Isacco
è geloso
del figlio
Alessio
che ha preso
le cose in mano
il padre
cieco
è circondato
da gente
che gli parla
di oracoli
e profezie
per cui
ritroverà
la vista
e ringiovanirà
e diventerà
imperatore
del mondo
quanto al giovane
Alessio
è accusato
di passare
il tempo
in orge
Sadomaso
con i suoi cortigiani
alla fine
inevitabilmente
arriva il colpo
di stato
un altro
grosso personaggio
che si chiama
dovinate
come si chiama
di nome
Alessio
Ducas
prende
il potere
fa fuori
sia il vecchio
Isacco
sia il giovane
Alessio
si incorona
imperatore
Alessio
quinto
a questo punto
nel campo
dei crociati
il discorso
è
no il discorso
non è uno solo
perché Roberto
Ecclery dice anche
quando abbiamo saputo
che era stato
ammazzato
Alessio
molti hanno detto
e chi se ne frega
tanto
non pagava
a me non me
importa proprio niente
altri hanno detto
eh no
è una vergogna
uno che si è permesso
di uccidere il suo signore
usurpare il trono
noi dobbiamo
vendicarlo
sono lì che discutono
su cosa fare
l'usurpatore
Alessio quinto
come dire
si gioca tutto
perché gli manda
a dire
che devono
andarsene
e quando si vedono
arrivare
questo messaggio
arrogante
che dice
adesso ve ne andate
i capi dei crociati
a quel punto
sono tutti d'accordo
chi
questo
questo ci manda
a dire queste cose
questo che ha
assassinato
il suo signore
di notte
a tradimento
lui viene a darci
degli ordini
ah ma adesso
gliela facciamo vedere
noi
avete capito
che gente sono
no normalmente
e come ragionano
e quali sono
le loro reazioni
gliela facciamo
vedere noi
e a quel punto
il discorso
è chiarissimo
signori
questi greci
sono dei traditori
sono gente
che non mantiene
i patti
sono degli assassini
dei criminali
non meritano niente
noi adesso
conquistiamo
l'impero
e ce lo prendiamo
noi
si mettono
d'accordo
i veneziani
e i crociati
francesi
ci spartiremo
Costantinopoli
e ci spartiremo
l'impero
metà per uno
eleggeremo
un imperatore
sarà uno
dei capi crociati
eleggeremo
un nuovo patriarca
di Costantinopoli
sarà un veneziano
metteremo
in comune
tutto il bottino
e queste decisioni
vengono comunicate
all'esercito
tutti sono informati
che adesso
per ristabilire
la giustizia
per sconfiggere
il malvagio
usurpatore
e per punire
questi malvagi
greci
che ora si comincia
anche a dire
che non vogliono
ubbidire a Roma
ubbidire al Papa
e quindi non si meritano
di essere indipendenti
allora noi adesso
conquisteremo
la città
e l'impero
il bottino
sarà messo
tutto in comune
e spartito
in parti uguali
in modo onesto
ci credono sul serio
eh
fanno giurare
tutti
che non stupreranno
le donne
e che non le spoglieranno
dei loro vestiti
che chi fosse colto
sul fatto
sarebbe ucciso
e fecero giurare
sui santi
che nessuno
avrebbe toccato
monaci
chierici
o preti
se non per difendersi
e che non avrebbero
saccheggiato
le chiese
e i monasteri
e l'assedio
ricomincia
con questo clima
stiamo quasi finendo
di entusiasmo
religioso
stavolta
perché davvero
Dio è con noi
loro sono comandati
da un infame
usurpatore assassino
e sono nemici
di Roma
Dio è con noi
e in effetti
sembra proprio
che Dio e la Madonna
siano con loro
perché quando
l'usurpatore
esce in battaglia
portando con sé
la grande icona
della Madonna
che da sempre
gli imperatori bizantini
portano con sé
in battaglia
e che promette
la vittoria
i crociati
vincono
e si impadroniscono
dell'icona
e la portano
nel loro campo
dove viene accolta
con immenso entusiasmo
da tutto il clero
con tutti i più grandi onori
la Madonna
è venuta
dalla nostra parte
l'usurpatore
torna in città
e cerca di nascondere
il fatto che ha perso
l'icona
poi però
dopo un po'
loro a questo punto
la portano fuori
in barca
come al solito
per farla vedere a tutti
l'icona
ce l'abbiamo noi
detto questo
l'assedio
all'inizio
non va bene
l'attacco
viene respinto
i greci
dalle mura
Roberto
e Clary
i greci
montarono
sulle mura
urlando
verso i
crociati
che tornavano
indietro
insomma
e si calavano
le brache
e gli mostravano
il culo
e a questo punto
nell'esercito crociato
si comincia
a avere qualche dubbio
ma che davvero
Dio è con noi
perché non vinciamo
e allora il clero
deve darsi da fare
e dire
no no
la battaglia è giusta
Dio è con noi di sicuro
questi sono nemici del Papa
nemici della vera fede
dicono che la legge di Roma
non vale niente
non è vero
e comunque
già che ci siamo
allontaniamo tutte le prostitute
dall'accampamento
è la prima volta
che veniamo a sapere
quello che potevamo
anche immaginarci
che come qualunque
accampamento militare
del passato
l'accampamento
dei crociati
è pieno di prostitute
ma in quel momento
quando bisogna
che Dio e la Madonna
siano con noi
ecco bisogna far vedere
che insomma
qualcosa facciamo
e finalmente
danno l'ultimo assalto
e arrivano a fare
una breccia
nelle mura
quelli da sopra
diranno giù
la pece bollente
i sassi
fanno una breccia
nelle mura
questo lo racconta
Robert de Clary
che di nuovo
era lì
e con lui
c'era suo fratello
che era un chierico
però evidentemente
era uno di quelli
che erano stati fatti chierici
per politica familiare
ma che come dire
sapeva fare meglio
qualcos'altro
Robert de Clary
racconta tutto
alla terza persona
dice eravamo lì
è stata fatta la breccia
e nessuno
osava entrare
e c'era lì
un chierico
si chiamava
Alehomme de Clary
che era sempre
il primo
in tutti gli assalti
quando Alehomme
il chierico
vide che nessuno
osava entrare
si fece avanti
e disse
che sarebbe entrato lì
che sarebbe entrato lui
scusatemi
e c'era lì
un cavaliere
suo fratello
si chiamava
Robert de Clary
che glielo proibì
e gli disse
che non sarebbe
affatto entrato
e il chierico
disse che l'avrebbe fatto
e si ficcò dentro
mani e piedi
e quando suo fratello
lo vide
lo prende per il piede
e comincia
a tirarlo fuori
finché
malgrado
suo fratello
che volesse o no
il chierico
entrò
quando fu dentro
gli corrono addosso
tantissimi greci
il chierico
tira fuori
il coltello
e gli corre incontro
e li fa scappare tutti
e a quel punto
entrano tutti
in città
si sparge la voce
che i crociati
sono entrati
i cittadini
cominciano
a seppellire
le loro ricchezze
sottoterra
in giardino
o a scappare
l'usurpatore
Alessio Quinto
tanto per cambiare
scappa in barca
anche lui
con la famiglia
i crociati
si fermano
perché
inoltrarsi
in questa immensa
città
anche se già
mezza devastata
dal fuoco
ma il giorno dopo
gli viene incontro
il clero
in processione
a chiedere
pace
e a questo punto
semplicemente
bisogna
accordare
agli uomini
dell'esercito
i tradizionali
tre giorni
di saccheggio
perché è un esercito
che ha preso
con la forza
una città
per le leggi
di guerra
ha diritto
al saccheggio
ordinato
organizzato
avete giurato
di non stuprare
nessuno
avete giurato
di mettere in comune
il bottino
andate
Robert de Clary
racconta il saccheggio
in termini
idillici
dopo che la città
fu presa
non si fece male
a nessuno
né povero
né ricco
e chi volle
andarsene
se ne andò
e chi volle
restare
rimase
dopo di che
anche Robert
spalanca gli occhi
non vi immaginate
il bottino
dalla creazione
del mondo
non fu visto
un simile bottino
né al tempo
di Alessandro
di Carlo Magno
e voi capite
voi capite
cosa hanno in testa
loro
cos'è che hanno letto
cos'è che gli hanno
raccontato
come fai a dargli
torto
chi sono i grandi uomini
Alessandro Magno
perché
ha fatto grandi conquiste
Carlo Magno
perché
ha fatto grandi conquiste
e anche noi
abbiamo fatto grandi conquiste
e poi però
la meraviglia
Roberto Clery
a questo punto
dedica sei pagine
a descrivere
le meraviglie
di Costantinopoli
e la parola
torna fuori
continuamente
e si meravigliarono
molto
della chiesa
di Santa Sofia
e in un altro posto
c'era un'altra
meraviglia
e descrive
l'ippodromo
con le sue gradinate
e c'era nella città
un'altra meraviglia
e descrive
delle statue
e un'altra meraviglia
e tutte queste meraviglie
ve le ho raccontate
ma ce n'erano
molte di più
che non possiamo
mica raccontarvi
tutte queste meraviglie
trovarono i francesi
in Costantinopoli
quando l'ebbero
conquistata
e dice Robert
qui mi fermo
perché se uno
vi raccontasse
un centesimo
delle meraviglie
che abbiamo trovato
sembrerebbe
una cosa
di fantasia
e non gli crederebbe
nessuno
ora
e chiudiamo
il bello
è che questa storia
ce la racconta
anche Niceta Cognata
che era lì
dalla parte
di quelli
che sono stati
conquistati
e Niceta
devo dire
conferma
che il saccheggio
non è stato
caratterizzato
da eccessi
di atrocità
non è stato ammazzato
non parla mai
di qualcuno
che viene ammazzato
descrive
questi invasori
questi barbari
irritabili
che cercano
i soldi
l'oro
sempre pronti
a gridare
a minacciare
descrive
gente malmenata
spogliata
donne violentate
quelle sì
entrano nelle case
chiedendo ai padroni
di tirar fuori
le ricchezze nascoste
malmenando alcuni
molti altri
invece
trattandoli bene
ma usando minacce
nei confronti
di tutti
e poi dice
è vero
che a un certo punto
hanno detto
va bene
chi vuole andarsene
può andarsene
e anche noi
ce ne siamo andati
e qui comincia
a raccontare
la sua vicenda
personale
lui che era
un grande personaggio
un ministro
un uomo molto ricco
che però ha perso
il palazzo
nell'incendio
e adesso sta
in un'altra casa
dice ci eravamo
trasferiti
in una casa
porticata
di difficile accesso
con l'ingresso
buio
l'ideale
per nascondersi
data la situazione
per cui dice
tutti i nostri amici
sono venuti
a casa nostra
eravamo tutti lì
e fra gli altri
nostri amici
c'era un veneziano
che abitava
a Costantinopoli
da tanto tempo
con cui noi
facevamo affari
perché era piena
anche di occidentali
la città appunto
e questo veneziano
ci ha aiutati
questo veneziano
ci ha tenuto
lontano
i saccheggiatori
poi ci ha aiutati
a uscire
dalla città
quando è stato
il momento
e siamo usciti
dalla città
i servi
erano spariti
tutti
eravamo noi
di famiglia
gli amici
con i bambini
in collo
a piedi
siamo usciti
incrociavamo
i barbari
a cavallo
che ci guardavano
male
poi dopo un po'
ci siamo accorti
che i barbari
guardavano
soprattutto le ragazze
allora abbiamo detto
alle ragazze
di sporcarsi
la faccia
col fango
e di stare
in mezzo
al gruppo
e così siamo arrivati fuori
ma eravamo appena
quasi usciti
che è arrivato
un altro barbaro
particolarmente arrogante
ha visto una ragazzina
del nostro gruppo
ha voluto prendersi
era strattonata
se l'è portata dietro
e se ne è andato
portandosela dietro
e noi gli siamo corsi
dietro
urlando
e poi per fortuna
abbiamo incontrato
degli altri barbari
che parlavano
un po'
la nostra lingua
e gli abbiamo spiegato
cosa succedeva
e questi sono venuti
con noi
e abbiamo raggiunto
questo tizio
che era entrato
in una casa
portandosi dietro
la ragazza
e gli altri barbari
gli sono andati addosso
e gli hanno detto
che doveva lasciarla andare
questo non voleva
poi alla fine
l'hanno costretto
io
dice Niceta
gli ho ricordato
che avevano giurato
di lasciar stare le donne
e alla fine
questo qua
ha lasciato andare
la ragazza
e noi abbiamo potuto
andarcene
questi abomini
commisero
gli eserciti
venuti dall'occidente
contro un popolo cristiano
Robert de Clary
e qui chiudo davvero
dice ancora un'altra cosa
non è finita bene
la spartizione del bottino
tutta la gente
ha portato il bottino
in comune
e poi l'oro
è tutto sparito
i capi
che sorvegliavano
il tesoro
hanno cominciato
a prenderselo loro
e lì hanno cominciato
a comportarsi male
verso la gente comune
si sono presi
i migliori alloggi
tutto il bottino
più prezioso
per noi
gente normale
è rimasto solo
l'argento
l'oro è sparito
e poi però
i capi
l'hanno pagata
molto cara
perché in realtà
la storia
non finirebbe qui
perché poi
ci sarebbe la storia
di come i capi
dei crociati
hanno nominato
un imperatore
e si sono spartiti
l'impero
e poi negli anni
successivi
sono tutti morti
combattendo
contro i greci
o contro altri
barbari
e Robert
che invece
è tornato a casa
in Piccardia
con delle preziose
reliquie
che ha regalato
alla parrocchia
e ha avuto il tempo
di raccontare
questa storia
ecco
e lui appunto
lo dice
gli altri
l'hanno pagata
molto cara
come sentirete poi
e va avanti
a raccontarla
ma noi invece
non lo faremo
voi lo sentirete
forse un'altra volta
questo resto
della storia
grazie
grazie a tutti
buonanotte
grazie